so my question is
uh what can you know about the new show
that you'll be doing and when can we
expect it and would you still be doing
the remotes that we all love uh that's a
very good question
question is first of all um it's the
same question that uh hbo max is asking
me all the time
so conan that show that you were gonna
do right after the old one uh-huh
guys you ever have a term paper when you
were in high school
and it was due on a thursday
and thursday came by you didn't have it
no uh we are working on something i
can't tell you exactly when it's when
it's going to come out it will not be a
night to night show
um
and i can't say too much about it but
what i will say is that
um i think what i'd like to do
or focus on is the stuff
i do that i think maybe i'm particularly
useful at or or adept at
and um
i want to double down on all that so
when you talk about remotes and things
where i'm with real people and in real
situations
that's exactly the kind of stuff that
i'm thinking about and that's what i
want to do it's a real
it's just a joy when i walk around
people come up to me and because of
youtube
there's all this
stuff
somewhat with some with sona
there's you know there's stuff with uh
obviously with kevin hart and ice cube
but then there's stuff
you know when i go to the american girls
store and i'm uh
uh you know the commercial acting one i
loved um yeah there's just so many
different so many different ones and
some of them you know from the old show
from the late night show going back to
the to the 90s which is crazy to say
that now but um
those those are really meaningful to me
and i love people will come up to me and
they have just seen them and i mean all
over the world if i go when i travel
people will say yeah i just saw that one
where you went to a korean spa yeah you
know um and i saw your whole body and i
can't unsee it uh yeah in in countries
where your show never aired they know
you because of of youtube and your
remotes yeah and it's really nice
because uh
the stuff that i like about that comedy
is
um and the jordan stuff people go crazy
for the jordan stuff and
jordan in italy and just the different
times i mean i've and and i mean i've
been in parts of the world
you know i was in uh i think i was in
ghana
and someone on the street asked me is
jordan for real how much of that is i'm
like
i'm in africa yeah
how do you even know who i am but they
do they know and it's really
a joy and so i'd like to i would like to
add to that
um mountain of foolishness i would love
to add some more foolishness to that
mountain uh that pile
um and so uh i can't tell you exactly
when that's gonna happen but um i will
tell you that
and and covid as you can imagine has
made it difficult to get out and around
and
um
so i i think i'm quite optimistic that
we're turning a corner and that things
are going to get better and then i can't
wait to get back out there